You may have heard about the intelligence of celebrities
But how is IQ measured and how can it be stacked?
One of the most common tests involves recognizing emotions in people's faces
For example, what is this expression?
Do you think it is a sign of embarrassment, sadness, amusement or shyness?
If you guessed it is an embarrassment sign you are right!
This test is used to help measure your ability to empathize and communicate effectively with others
So let's look at the most common intelligence test - the IQ test, also known
In the name of IQ
It is a standardized test that evaluates verbal and nonverbal abilities
Study the sequence of this geometric pattern at the moment
Now of these six squares, which tiles will you choose to complete the pattern?
I'll give you a few seconds, but pause the video if you need more time
If you choose form number five, then you are right!
Basically, each row contains a diamond, square and triangle
In addition to a solid bar and padded bar and empty bar
Since this bottom row contains a triangle and a diamond, we know the following square, as it has
Tape is empty and padded, so we know we need a solid tape
The direction of the tape is the same on each line
Although IQ tests are common, there are other ways to test whether you are smart
There is now a prominent theory of "multiple intelligences," such as rhythmic musical intelligence
To test your audio!
Which of these songs sounds "out of range" for you?
The first tune?
The second tone?
Or the third tune?
If you guessed in the third section, this means that you have a good sense about the vocal layers
Although it is not fully understood, you can be deaf-mouthed and still have a perfect hearing though
How your brain interprets sounds that are hard to interpret
Now, what about your optical intelligence?
I'll show you a picture of these six shapes for ten seconds
Try to remember it as best you can!
Well now which of these three models have you seen already?
If you guessed the "C" you are right!
This task requires the use of Ziggernes objects - fictional objects that do not exist in real life
In order to test you accurately
If you are well on the Zegrens mission you may have higher optical intelligence and it is not
Same IQ
But this may mean that you will excel in tasks such as matching fingerprints, and interpreting medical x-rays
Or tracking aircraft on radar screens
Not all intelligence, for example, can be measured by physical intelligence
Being able to handle things skillfully is difficult to break up
The study of children aged four years in one of the ballet classes could not effectively assess the rhythm because some
He has taken lessons before or has been dancing at home creating a prior knowledge
Many intelligence tests also require a combination of many types of intelligence, so it is difficult
Study only one type
What this research confirms is that there are many ways to be intelligent
It is not just about testing intelligence
Translation: شوان حميد Twitter: shwan_hamid @